Michael osterholm is the director of the
Center for infectious disease research
and policy at the University of
Minnesota that's in Minneapolis
dr. good morning you know there are a
lot of people right now who are worried
have I been exposed have I not been
exposed so to that question how long
does it take from exposure to the moment
when they feel some sort of a symptom
and what do they do then well first of
all most people likely will feel some
symptoms even if they're mild as you
just described and that usually occurs
between four to five days after you've
actually been exposed to the virus some
people feel no symptoms right a doctor I
mean in and can still actually spread
this well there's two different pieces
to that the first one is will I shed the
virus or basically expose others before
I get sick and the data now are quite
compelling that yes that does occur a
day or two at least before you have any
symptoms at all your infectious so
during that time period none of us would
even know that we're transmitting it or
that we're with someone who is infected
then there's the second question you're
asking do some people just not ever have
any symptoms and we sure sure that that
happens but I think it's one where they
may be mild enough that people just
don't realize that they're sick they may
have a slight coughing itchy scratchy
throat of cetera but so it's not like
there's lots of people out there who
have no symptoms whatsoever
so in terms of exposure doctor there's
there's people there's social distancing
there's also surfaces plastic cardboard
metal do we have any idea of how long
the virus can live on those surfaces
well you know again we're learning more
about this virus and we're extrapolating
what we know about influenza and what we
know about the other corona viruses but
I think there's actually a growing body
that's of information that says that
some of what we've been sharing actually
hasn't been correct
number one is is that this virus moves a
lot further than six feet away from
people so that if I'm in a crowded room
I may very well be breathing in the air
is someone who is infected doesn't even
know it and now I'm infected
second of all the surface issue I think
has been greatly overplayed and that you
know it for one reason it makes us feel
good to know that we can wash our hands
but I think we've turned it to the
extreme for example all this deep
cleaning
and all the video you see of people
cleaning in the streets probably has
very very little to do with stopping
transmission virus Kenya survive on a
surface but but it's not it's not likely
highly infectious at all way dr. Ostrom
the more we here the worse it sounds you
know dr. pouchy said yesterday if people
think we're overreacting that's a good
thing but I see so many people are
saying are we taking things too far what
can you say to people to let them know
you've got to take this very very
seriously the precautions you take yes
water yeah I think III might have a
slight disagree with my good friend Tony
that I don't think that's called
overreaction I think what we want to do
is do what makes a difference straight
talk with people that tell them what
makes a difference and then when we
don't know so say so I mean a good
example for today is that we I don't
really have the data the supports that
this is a problem in school children of
them transmitting the virus to each
other than bringing it home like we do
with flu absolutely have that with flu
and their downsides are closing schools
we're losing up to 20% of our main
health care worker force right now
because they have to stay home with kids
so I think that that we want to do
everything we can but we know right now
that that surely is still going to keep
spreading all right dr. Ulster home
thank you very much we appreciate